on wall street you're only as good as
your last trade so what happens when you
make a bad one scott minert is in charge
of guiding investment strategies for
guggenheim partners which oversees 325
billion dollars he also leads research
on global macroeconomics here's his big
money mistake one of the most difficult
things i went through in my life was the
period right out of college i moved to
fort lauderdale florida i was working
for pricewaterhouse and it was 1980 and
real estate prices had been skyrocketing
in florida
and so i wanted to get in on the real
estate boom
and so i um i managed to scrape together
everything i had
and i found this condominium that i
could just get into and
i bought it
and of course i had to pay a big payment
how much were the interest rates
uh at that time i got a a special
subsidized mortgage which was nine and
seven eight percent
right and that was low because most
rates were like 14 or 15 or 16.
and um
you know i thought i was getting my foot
in my foot in the door but it didn't
take me long
until after i closed which probably was
a few weeks when i started to have
second thoughts why well
it just something in the pit of my
stomach
didn't
so it was first a gut instinct it's gut
right but you know but of course this is
a short bet so you know just ignore it
that was the prevailing wisdom at the
time you know real estate you can't go
wrong oh especially then because this is
the heyday of inflation
uh i mean
it had been like the number one
performing asset
for at least five years when did you
realize that it was a mistake well you
mean fully a mistake because it was
about a week after closing i started to
have second thoughts
i began to realize you know as as prices
began to
to soften and decline and sales are
going in and
curiously as an auditor
i was assigned to cadillac fairview it
was the largest real estate developer in
the world at that time
and they had made a fortune in 79 on a
project in miami beach they sold out the
entire high rise
in half a day
two years later
um
you know there there's concern that
they're stuck with a lot of inventory
there was a cover story on
fortune magazine called getting burned
at the beach not a good sign no and so
they decide they're going to prove
everybody wrong and they're going to
hold an auction and they're going to
sell
everything and the way it worked is
whoever the highest bidder was got to
pick any unit
he wanted he could actually could pick
up the five
so uh this this young guy must have been
in his 20s who was venezuelan
bid like two and a half million dollars
and i get a nudge from the cfo
and he points down the row and i lean
forward and look down and i see the ceo
of cadillac fairview linking forward
giving me the big thumbs up
right within 20 units
of bidding the prices were at 50 000
there were literally thousands of units
for sale so was that like 10 minutes 20
minutes later yeah
just absolutely
and money of course right the the guy
who was you know wanted the absolute
best unit was gonna bid whatever to make
sure he won yeah and you know all the
bids completely faded and
i learned a lesson that you know not
only was i stuck personally in a piece
of real estate that wasn't worth what i
paid for it but that that real estate
was a um
you know
was a very volatile asset class and that
the old adage that real estate always
goes up
was you know one of the great laws so
tell me more about this apartment in
florida what was the name of the complex
i can't even remember
was there a view no i mean yeah you
could see swampland i mean the how the
there was nothing around us there was
this
um you know sort of
irrigation drainage canal that ran
beside the property and so not
picturesque no no the alligators would
crawl up on the lawn from time to time
and what was the listing price
it was i think it was 54
750. you remember this when you suffered
through something
it's very exact and you said your
monthly payment on the mortgage was
about 600
and your annual salary at the time was
only fifteen thousand okay that was the
mortgage and taxes i started to feel
like a captive that i was a prisoner to
the i couldn't it wasn't like you know
if i if i decided i wanted to change
jobs or move somewhere i was tied down
with this property
so this is something that is recurring
because housing markets go in cycles and
including at this moment when housing is
is very doing very well right how did
you extricate yourself from this real
estate investment in florida like how
does it end with a happy story no no
you know it ends uh about almost 20
years later well you held on to it from
1980 it's gonna come back
right and i rented it and did you make
money on renting no
right because by the time i had the
maintenance and the whole bit and
and of course i had reached
for the only thing i could afford which
wasn't going to be the creme de la creme
you know location location location that
had everything going against it it's
what i could afford yeah and so uh it
was actually
um in the uh
probably around 2002 2003
i finally sold it at a loss
2000 to 2003 this is after you retired
unretired came back to work at
guggenheim was
leading the firm
that's when you sold the department at a
loss right you won't it was going to
come back
by the way what's really funny is when i
sold it
i was like look
i could see the dynamic that was
starting to develop in real estate and
i'm like this thing's going to take off
again and it did
so you saw the right before took off or
yeah
but the thing is i was just so
disgusted with dealing with it and
somebody approached me and wanted to buy
it and i'm like you know i just want out
did you make a phone call to anyone
about this i mean did you
tell anyone about this this experience
or were you no i was hiding i was you
were hiding one was embarrassed you know
my family saw me do this everybody saw
me do this and
i'd actually actually gone to my
grandparents to get some of the down
payment
and
i when i got the proceeds from the sale
and i had positive cash my i sent it to
my grandmother and i said i'm paying you
back the money i borrowed for the
condominium and i couldn't
convince her that i'd lost money
really well it had been so long and she
was like you clearly made out better oh
yeah you know you're such a smart
investor and the whole bit like but you
know it's like really begging her to
believe me she never believed me so is
this something you think you could have
learned from a textbook or from someone
telling you or did you have to
experience it firsthand yourself to
really understand
that real estate can go south uh oh i
think
you know
it taught me a lot about um
the usefulness of history
because florida south florida in
particular is notorious for real estate
booms and busts going back to the 20s
and so um you know it probably affected
the way i looked at all investments
going forward which was not to just
listen to the conventional wisdom of
what everybody else was saying but to to
take what they were saying and you know
actually you know really in reality
challenge any time i hear people say
that something is a foregone conclusion
um alarm bells are going off in your
head yeah exactly and i start looking at
it and seeing what it is and you know
candidly you know we're going through
one of those periods right now where
it's a foregone conclusion that
inflation is here to stay
and
you know i'm not quite buying into the
story we're having an inflation spike
but
you know that's the foregone that's the
conventional wisdom how often are you
reminded of this
uh of this specific thing
not too often
uh but the general
idea a
lot because it's um you know it's i
think
prudence
in investing prudence in life
uh you know have uh some real value
even if you miss out on some upside in
the meantime you know what there's
always a bull market somewhere if you
start into the world if i'm missing out
on something uh you know it's fomo
right and so we've seen a lot of fomo in
the last year or two and uh you know
you know as i would tell i sold somebody
the other day my and my personal
investments are like most people down at
this point
uh but the number if i told you relative
to my net worth is pretty de minimis
because you know whenever i see fomo i
kind of
say maybe it's time to go in the other
direction
[Music]
[Music]
you